كيف يتميز هذا المسلسل وشجعك انك تشارك
فيه العمل ابتداء من وقت ما قراناه على
الورق كان
نص رائع اكثر من رائع مؤثر وهو على الورق
فكان صعب وجديد علي الموضوع تماما انه
شخصيه مركبه
ومعقده
وما بين
الخير والشر
والطين والنار
مغري لاي ممثله تبغى تظهر
موهبتها في التمثيل في تفاصيل كثيره جدا
قصه مختلفه
من كل النواحي من البيئه بيئه التصوير
بيئه
الخط حق رحمه كامل مختلف تماما وغير انه
فكره انسانيه جدا في قافله حجاج من اليمن
فجابت الريح
بضعت انا وعيال
وهجموا علينا قطع الطرق
شلوا مني عيالي حلوه
في المسار اللي انا فيه الصعوبات اللي
واجهناها
كنا بنصور اغلب الاوقات واغلب الايام في
الصحراء وبين جبال وكنا في عز الصيف درجه
الحراره تحت اشعه الشمس 55 54
كانت صعوبه الملابس ثقلها
فوق بعض فكان صعب علينا جدا مع حراره
الشمس والجو السخن اشربي
مضارب عربنا ما هي بعيده ولا وصلنا ضمدوها
الحريم من اكثر الاشياء اللي كانت بعد
صعبه عليه انه
رحمه ام الاربعه اطفال وانا في الحقيقه
انا مو ام لسا ما تزوجت
كان عندي صراحه انه شلون انا بطلع مشاعر
الامه هذه
تكون صادقه وحقيقيه من دون ما اكون اوفر
[موسيقى]
عدد ما يحتلني الرقم الان لكن عشرات
الجنسيات مشاركه في العمل
عشرات الثقافات مهم جدا
في عمل خاصه ملحمه زي هذا العمل مهم جدا
في البدايه انه
نعرف العالم على قدرتنا قوتنا ابتداء من
الكتابه والانتاج والاخراج والصناعه
والاداء والتمثيل وانتهاء
بانفتاحنا في الوقت الحالي على الاعمال
العالميه اللي بتصير
من الاعمال اللي تخاطب كل العالم مو بس
الفئه فئه الوطن العربي
وهذا بالقصص الثانيه اللي موجوده فيها
اجنبيه ما هي عربيه اعتقد ان شاء الله انه
هذه رساله واضحه لكل العالم ان احنا نقدر
نصنع صناعه عالميه ومحترفه جدا الله لا
يطعمك فراقنا
انا شرت الشيخ على العرب اللي الطريقه
للحجاج وعلمني منهم
وبس تتشافه ساقك
نسافر وندور على عيالك